[Music]
Batman destroys the Justice League and
the ending of this comic is amazing but
this opens up with Batman going to visit
the graves of his parents only to find
out that Hell's Bells somebody dug up
his parents'
Graves damn i' never heard the like now
at that point you switch over to Martian
Manhunter right now Martian Manhunter
who's just kind of doing his thing in
patrolling he's basically hit by a
missile but it doesn't explode it
doesn't detonate instead he doesn't
fully understand what it is using his
microscopic vision and all the stuff
that he can do he basically Zooms in
right looks in and sees these little
nanites that immediately Bond themselves
to his skin and so at that point you
switch over to the flash Wally West and
Wonder Woman Who are basically
investigating a fire in Germany's Black
Forest now once they get there and they
start doing a little bit of
investigating they see just like this
dude who's just running like a
madman through the forc setting
everything on fire now they ultimately
catch up to this guy they chase up to
this guy as fast as they can but this
guy starts putting up a fight right
literally just like hitting him with
tree trunks the whole nine yards he hits
the flash with a tree trunk and sends
this guy flying ultimately The Flash is
able to create a kind of Whirlwind and
basically dissolve and really D the
Flames only for them to realize it's
Martian Man Hunter that this guy with
those nanites that attached to him had
basically set him on fire in some way
now we will find out exactly how this
was done and how Batman ties into it but
I got to be honest with you guys man
Imagining the Martian Man Hunter in like
a live action or an animated film just
running through the forest screaming
while he's on
fire that sounds
hilarious I'm sorry people it's not
funny that's not funny but it is to me
but here's the thing at that point you
switch over to the United Nations now
the United Nations and everything going
on here is kind of a background and it
actually be a little more important once
we get towards the end in effect
tensions in the Middle East are
basically escalating but what ends up
happening here is of course you have
these assassins that are going after a
combination of Plastic Man and Aquaman
and literally they just like bust into
the place and just immediately attack
these guys now Plastic Man I see all
these videos of people who are talking
about how powerful Plastic Man is
plastic man's not that powerful you know
what plastic man's weakness is the left
side of your refrigerator being frozen
that that's what plastic man's weakness
is because they shoot this guy with a
canister that literally just freezes him
in place and then just hit him with a
attack hammer and he shatters so much
for plastic man right just one of the
strongest characters in DC Comics right
like have that guy standing anarctica
for 15 minutes and we'll see just how
powerful he really is you know what I
mean but with Aquaman it's actually a
lot more interesting Aquaman gets hit
with a canister that just kind of like
douses him in these fumes we don't
immediately find out what it is that's
going on with him instead what ends up
happening is that because most everybody
knows that Aquaman is a guy who talks to
fish and whenever he's out of water he
has to kind of go back it's one of those
weird things about his character for you
know as the side here right in all
seriousness when it comes to Aquaman and
water it really is just relative to DC
Comics at that point in time there's
been stories where he's been able to
spend a pronged amount of time outside
of water and there were stories where
you couldn't like be out of water for
any more than a couple hours so it just
kind of changes based on the history
here but the long and short of it is he
has to return to water at some point in
time but this is really difficult for
him to do because apparently this myth
that he was D with makes him afraid of
water he's terrified of it right which
basically forces him to seal his own
fate now at that point you jump to the
Justice League Watchtower right this
giant satellite space station that
orbits Earth Superman basically
examining the nanites that were on the
skin of Martian Manhunter comes to the
realization that they contain Trace
elements of magnesium in effect he
bursts into flame in open air that's
literally what happened with him he
basically became a human torch but like
a lot less cool Plastic Man is just in
pieces and the Flash is trying to put
him back together he will become
important later on kind of not really
but he'll basically reappear as you
would expect from plastic man he
essentially survives and literally
they're just trying to find some way to
tend to Aquaman because he keeps just
putting up a fight with everybody every
time they try to bring water to him now
at that point they reach out to Batman
because they come to this realization
people are targeting members of the
Justice League and so Batman's just kind
of like I'm dealing with a thing right
like I'm Batman I've had something that
I have to prep for because I'm Batman I
always have prep time even when it comes
to preparing for things it would be
impossible to prepare for because nobody
could see it coming like a giant teddy
bear in the sky that decides that the
world needs to end who's going to prep
for that Batman because you know he
preps for everything but what you end up
getting is them just kind of putting
members of the league and what are
basically in stasis but Aquaman has this
kind of mental breakthrough right like
the task of the Flash and Wonder Woman
is to go find Kyle rer who we'll talk
about a little bit more here in a little
while because for new people they
probably don't know a whole lot about
his character but while they're doing
that Aquaman just kind of has this
thought right he's like how did they
find myself and Plastic Man how did they
locate us right like no one on earth
knew that we were there but then it
Dawns on him oh my God right and so
before you find out what that is you
basically switch over to Superman who is
in Metropolis and just kind of you know
kind of understanding everything that's
going on and yeah he's doing his thing
anyway what's important here is he gets
into the office of Perry white his boss
his editor that kind of thing when he
reads one of the newspapers it's all
gibberish right and the reason why is
because we find out the person that's
basically behind all this but not really
is rozal ghoul rozal gou is behind it
but there's a whole different caveat
here which is really really awesome but
in effect Raza goul had turned on a kind
of communications tower that affects the
human brain and what it does is it sends
a kind of constant signal out there that
made the whole world
dyslexic no one sees sentence structure
in its proper form everything is all
just Babble and so as you can imagine
the entirety of the written word just
completely and totally collapses it's
one of the coolest things here you're
going to see that like this scheme he
has is really really dope and if a
person managed to find some way to do
this in the real world things would go
belly up within like a day right like
one day like the world would basically
fall apart but of course you have Wally
West and you have Wonder Woman that get
to the apartment of Kyle rer now Kyle
rer for those of you guys who are not
familiar with his character he became
the newest Green Lantern after the
events of emerald Twilight when how
Jordan basically went nuts declared
himself Parallax and wiped out pretty
much all the Green Lanterns and the
Guardians of the universe git the
surviving guardian of the universe at
the time and the people who made the
Green Lantern rings he gives the final
ring to Kyle rer and then he dies Kyle
rer depending on who you talk to people
liked him better because his constructs
were way more advanced because he was
like a comic book artist so instead of
just being like how Jordan who creates a
big boxing glove Kyle Rainer would
create like a giant Mech right it was
pretty dope like some of the constructs
he made were really really dope the
issue is when they get into the
apartment of Kyle Kyle's blind son the
dudes Hell's Bells the dude's even got
white eyes he can't see anything right
this dude is blind well no pun int this
guy's blind as a bat right literally
that's what it is and so at that point
you have Batman attacking and really
going after Raz Al ghoul coming to the
realization quite quickly that Raz Al
ghoul is the one that's behind all this
stuff but then Raz Al goul reveals a
caveat to Batman which is of course he's
the one that dug up his parents but he's
got them suspended over the Lazarus pits
which basically would mean one of two
things would happen either they would
just succumb to the Lazarus pits and
they would just kind of melt and that
would be the the end of it and Batman
would have to witness the desecration of
his parents' dead bodies or they would
come back to life so was kind of crazy
right it's even one of these things
where razal ghoul kind of taunts him a
little bit but at that point you switch
back over to Wonder Woman and Kyle rer
now Kyle rer kind of starts freaking out
over the fact that he's blind it does
have a lot to do with his Green Lantern
ring in the sense that that's really
where he found a kind of greater sense
of purpose not being able to see means
that yes he can conjure constructs but
he doesn't know what he's sending them
to right so there could be a villain
like on his left side and he just like
fires a construct straight ahead of him
right so he just wouldn't be able to
effectively be a superhero in any
meaningful way the other part of this is
that as a graphic designer all of his
work and really his identity comes down
to his eyesight so waking up one day
which is literally what happened he just
woke up blind but waking up one day and
being completely and totally unable to
see everything that he knows about his
life comes Crashing Down so it's not
just the fact that he's blind it's the
fact that he's lost any and all sense of
purpose for himself but that's when
Aquaman contacts Wonder Woman and the
Flash and says Be Ready an attack is
coming and they're like what are you
talking about and he's like they are
using our communication devices that's
how they're finding us as soon as that
statement's made these guys bust into
the door right fire one they fire a shot
off at the flash fire two they fire a
shot off at Wonder Woman now here's a
cool thing when Wonder Woman is hit by
this shot what ends up happening is she
just sees this woman who's really kind
of cool looking if her being honest and
the two of them start fighting each
other and Wonder Woman just goes at it
right she's literally tearing this chick
up now Kyle rer despite the fact that
he's blind is doing what he can to try
to wake Wonder Woman up by essentially
kind of making his way toward her body
by finding the sounds but one of these
people Chim in and they say she can't
hear you the virtual reality chip in her
brain has her so firmly convinced that
she's engaged in unending Mortal Kombat
that her body is undergoing all the
rigors of her imagined exertion the man
who designed this trap realized that
Wonder Woman's competitive nature can be
a great weakness in battle all that
could make her surrender is a heart
attack so literally she's fighting to
the death against an enemy that doesn't
exist for the flash when they fire that
shot on him is actually a kind of
pulsing device that attaches itself to
his spinal cord and he starts
experiencing basically epileptic
seizures at light speed right it just
paralyzes this guy there's literally
nothing he can do now what Superman ends
up doing is he races off and basically
grabs a device right the way that he
explains it is he says like it's
relation to Brainiac right he says The
Brainiac at one point put a giant force
field over metropolis and that he saved
the apparatus right the Superman can
rewire it to emit a counter frequency
that can basically blanket Metropolis in
a white noise Dome and effectively give
people back the ability to see speech or
at least to see language as it's
actually written as opposed to seeing it
with dyslexic eyes right their brain
kind of being reworked but then you get
like this really cool moment from Kyle
rer because what you get is them just
kind of making fun of him like they
literally crack him over the head with
the butt of a rifle and just kind of
send him crashing down to the ground and
then he just like lashes out right he
was like okay look yes I can't see but
what I do know is you are all in this
room and that everybody else who's here
can withstand the power of my Lantern
rings but you cannot so he just kind of
goes berserk and fires these just
projectiles off in every direction it
looks like a video game finishing move
if we're being honest with ourselves
which kind of makes perfect sense
because that was literally Kyle rck
Right video games comic books like
literally he was the comic book reader
in the 1990s he just have having to be a
DC character but at the end of the day
none of it really matters because he
cannot see his Target and so as Valiant
as this effort is and as interesting as
this attack is it doesn't really do any
good that instead he's just shot from
behind and he's incapacitated and that's
basically it now following that you
switch back over to Batman who is still
kind of being taunted by Ral goul with
the idea of like you know wouldn't you
want to see your mom and dad again you
know kind of thing let you all kind of
stuff basically messing with his
emotions but then also revealing that
like his whole plan is to effectively
just bring the world crashing down which
for the most part was like always the
plan of Rosal ghoul in a lot of the
earlier not really earlier stories but
like the stories from like the 80s and
90s right to basically destroy society
as we know it he was almost kind of like
an extreme environmentalist potentially
you could look at it that way right but
just create fear in pandemonium but then
what he does here is he reveals to
Batman that he holds a piece of red
cryptonite and so jumping back to the
scene with like Kyle rer and Wonder
Woman and all those guys Martian
Manhunter shows up the kicker about all
this is that in order to keep himself
from bursting into flame due to the
nanites that are still attached to his
skin he's actually wearing a suit that
was designed for atlantans to stay on
land for a prolonged period of time the
issue with this is that outside of his
enhanced strength and really his
telepathy it basically Nerfs every other
ability that he has because if the suit
is damaged in any way scratched cut
whatever and it creates an opening in
the suit he'll burst into flame again at
the same time if my high school
chemistry serves me correctly and it's
been over 20 years so I'm not going to
swear by this magnesium does not oxidize
itself basically meaning that if the
suit were damaged and this is water
inside the suit that the Magnesium
attached to his skin would separate the
oxygen and hydrogen atoms and it would
just continue to burn by burning the
oxygen not only that it would probably
create some kind of like flammable
hydrogen gas or something along those
lines again it's been 20 something years
since I had chemistry in high school so
you know if somebody knows more than me
feel free to explain the point that I'm
making here is if the suit gets damaged
things go sideways fast and so what ends
up happening is that the suit is almost
hit right it's almost damaged Superman
shows up basically cauterizes the wound
or cauterizes the opening and then
that's when the fight is essentially on
but Batman tries to get out of rozal
ghoul's Base as fast as he possibly can
and the reason for that is because what
you have here is RZ Al ghoul's daughter
Talia al goul and what she has in her
possession is the exact red Kryptonite
that Ros showed to Batman right two
different samples of the same substance
Batman manages to make his escape from
ozal ghoul's base and he immediately
calls for Superman to retreat he didn't
say it before just because of the fact
that the nature of the base blocked
communication so he couldn't actually
say anything while he was there with
Ross but the point is he tells Superman
get out of there it's fast as you
possibly can and he says that's why
razal ghoul wanted me distracted he
couldn't risk my warning you all the
plans the traps the signal trackers they
were all mine like Superman I did this
to you and the Justice leag right this
was all Batman right like he literally
says like yes I did this I can help you
you have to listen to me but then what
happens is another Tower is activated
and it actually just starts screwing up
the language centers of the brain what
that means is that while the world is
still dealing with global dyslexia now
they can't understand anything that
anyone is saying to them they might as
well all just be speaking gibberish and
so Batman is seemingly knocked off or at
least jumps off the side of a mountain
he's assumed dead by the henchmen of
razal ghoul and then you have Aquaman
who tries to activate a teleporter
plastic man comes back and the Plastic
Man activates a teleporter instead and
brings everybody in now now following
that and in order to deal with Aquaman
and to keep him alive they put him
inside a giant water tank but they Ed
telepathy or telepathic suggestion to
trick him into believing that he's still
actually out there in a desert so
basically it satisfies the part of his
brain that's been altered by that
chemical into being afraid of water
there's no water anywhere in sight but
his physical body is not going to die
because he's submersed in the way that
he needs to be the other thing that goes
on is that plastic man sends a finger
into the ear of Wonder Woman and removes
the device from her ear right so she no
longer sees this just you know entity
that's there that doesn't actually
exists but more so than that is Superman
so the thing that happened here with
Superman it's one of the coolest things
ever right what we're told here is that
when Kyle rer tries to basically talk to
Superman the response of Marshall
Manhunter is he can hear you Kyle in
fact right now he can hear a
grasshopper's heartbeat in Beijing the
mutating effects of Batman's red
Kryptonite have turned his skin
transparent consequently the solar
energy that powers him blazes directly
and excruciatingly into his organs and
muscles and so he literally says it's
everything Superman can do to keep from
exploding with power so in effect every
ability that he has that's derived from
yellow sun radiation has been Amplified
several times over right he's just
taking in way more energy than his body
has ever taken in before so he can't
really process and handle everything but
he kind of pulls it together just long
enough to basically laser the device
that's attached to the spine of The
Flash the flash of course goes back to
normal right he's no longer dealing with
epileptic seizures at light speed and
then they realized what was going on
with Kyle rainer's ring that Kyle rer
had never worn his ring whenever he went
to sleep and the reason for that is the
ring is powered by will but his concern
is that his conscious nightmares or his
subconscious thoughts could accidentally
cause the ring to do something it's
actually one of the cooler elements of
his character just so you guys know
things like that are why people loved
Kyle rer so much because DC Comics spent
a lot of time exploring not just his
abilities with the ring but what the
everyday life of Kyle wayer looked like
even when he had a power ring is
something that you never really saw them
do when it came to like hell Jordan
right so small little things like that
are what made him cool and so what they
realize is if he woke up with the ring
on his finger but he always goes to
sleep with the ring laying somewhere
next to him then someone came in in the
middle of the night and attached the
ring to his finger and because the Green
Lantern rings work on Willpower right
the most powerful uh object in the
universe anything the weer can imagine
becomes true somebody planted a hypnotic
suggestion in his mind that he's blind
and because the ring was on his finger
that became reality so it's as crazy as
it sounds the simplest way for him to
overcome his blindness is to just
believe he's not blind but because he
didn't even understand what was going on
the thought never crossed his mind that
that was a possibility it's a pretty
genius way to introduce just like a
weakness or a caveat to his character
and just kind of write him out of a
story or even out of like a huge portion
of DC Comics for a period of time if
that's what you wanted to do but more so
than that when it comes to Superman this
guy is really really struggling and the
reason why is because using his x-ray
vision and even his telescopic vision
and his super hearing and looking out
there onto the world what he sees is
that it's all falling apart people
cannot communicate with each other
through word or speech that orders to
keep from pressing the nuclear button or
to potentially set off nuclear bombs
that none of those orders are being
received people are dying on operating
room tables because doctors don't know
they can't see what the patient's
heartbeat is is they're just too afraid
to cut into them right the power of
speech and the power of the written word
literally controls the world as we know
it it's one of the most important things
like yes we as people function largely
through heuristics but those are all
based and predicated on speech and
writing without those two things the
quote unquote living by the rule of
thumb simply fails because those are
just the basics of human communication
and the basic functions of human society
so it's weird to see it all just kind of
come crashing down more so than that
what end up happening is you pick up
with Talia al ghoul who gets to Raz and
there's a statement that's made by one
of his henchmen which is like Batman's
basically dead and she just gets pissed
off and then she storms off after
attacking this guy because Talia al goul
always had a thing for Batman and the
fact the two of them are kind of banged
off and on for a while there is a point
where like you could call it the
relationship if you want to it's pretty
Twisted how it happens but it all kind
of comes to a head in like Batman and
Robin was it Batman and Robin or Batman
and Son by Grant Morrison I can never
remember which one but it's like the
introduction of Damen Wayne the Son of
Batman the biological child of Batman
and Talia al goul raised as an assassin
it's a phenomenal story right it's one
of the best stories from Batman's entire
history but then you also have this guy
who's just kind of listening right this
henchman this listening to everything
going on only for this guy to turn a
corner and walk away and for us to learn
that his Batman which is really kind of
weird because you think somebody would
have looked at him and just been like
hey man so like that guy's head has like
these two little pointer things at the
top that look very similar to like the
the mask that Batman wears I wonder if
that's him and they walk up and they
pull off the thing and it's like it is
Batman and he's like I would have gotten
away with it too if it wasn't for you
meddling kids I'm just saying like it
made the most sense to me but the bigger
Point here right this is the bigger
thing to take away from all of this the
entirety of the Justice League has come
to the realization that rozal goul was
only able to do and really take out the
Justice League the way that he was
because Batman created a series of
protocols designed for the purpose of
nullifying the Justice League right of
taking out the Justice League in effect
they found out that one of their own was
basically working on a way and had a way
to neutralize all of them it's a just
Monumental breach of trust right it's a
huge breach of trust and so Batman
basically chimes in and says hey look
like I have a location for us to go to
this is where we all need to meet up
they do question him right like is it
really just kind of track right what if
it's some kind of a Roose and so
Superman responds he shows up here now
Batman's taken one of the nullifiers of
rogl meaning that his speech can be
understood by anybody that he's talking
to and when everybody basically meets up
there you have Martian Manhunter who's
using his telepathy to communicate their
thoughts with one another because
thoughts themselves are not disrupted
it's simply the vocalization between how
the brain processes those thoughts and
how a person speaks that causes
everything to go sideways right that
miscommunication and so with them all
being able to communicate telepathically
with each other they all question
whether or not Batman is somebody that
they should be even allying with can
they trust this guy now this leads to
them basically launching their attack
against the you know Tower right which
kind of corrects speech for the most
part and at least as far as
communication goes sends everything back
to normal so they can all just talk
normally and even the world itself can
talk normally but then Talia al goul
chimes in and she says here's the bigger
thing that you have to worry about here
right she says despite the tower's
destruction there's remains enough of
Father's technology to beam this message
directly to the speech centers of your
minds and she says you think you've won
by eradicating that Tower but father put
a fail safe in place his goal was to
escalate worldwide tension into the
global Warfare and while you have
thwarted him on a grand scale even now
rastan is readying a biochemical strike
on neighboring Turkey right in essence
the middle is about to go to war and so
that's when it's kind of like okay so
like how do we deal with this because
even they kind of asked the question
like are we being played by razal
ghoul's daughter right is this yet like
another trap another Rouge right you
could see how little trust there is
between the members of the league and
when the question is asked like why
should we even trust her her response
because this time I have been used
callously by my father because I have
had enough of being a pawn in his
endless schemes this is no falsehood in
order to find father's biot terrorist
you must listen to me carefully but then
somebody comes in and somebody basically
shoots her incapacitates her and then
this guy says good luck right because
what you're looking for is a microscopic
weapon that's invisible to the naked eye
right and so while you guys are good you
specifically Batman you are not that
good right and they end the transmission
now ultimately this guy is basically
brought before razal ghoul for shooting
his daughter and then razal ghoul feeds
that guy to the Lions I just felt like
that little bit of a plot thread kind of
need to be wrapped up but at the end of
the day all the different members of The
League are all basically starting to
kind of come to terms and really
overcome the different weaknesses that
they have or the things that have been
done to them in the case of Martian
Manhunter for example that Martian skin
basically replenishes itself and
replaces itself pretty quickly much
faster than a humans does but no one
really accounted for this because they
expected him to basically burn to death
and so because of that he's able to
basically shed quite literally the
Magnesium lined skin that he has and now
he's able to walk around in the open air
without having to worry about being
caught on fire but Aquaman still locked
in a tank of water what you actually get
here is Martian Manhunter working with
him to help him overcome his fear of
Water by telling him to focus on the man
who's responsible for all this and to
channel that fear into hatred which will
allow him to overcome it of course focus
on Batman so it's just kind of driving
anger and hatred towards Batman and
that's one of the things to know here
yes the league is working together but
it's tenuous at best right it's one of
these things where we'll deal with you
later Batman for right now we need to go
deal with razal ghoul right and so for
the most part it goes exactly the way
that you would expect it to right they
ultimately find their way to razal
ghoul's base and then what you have is
the team basically splitting in two that
Wonder Woman and Plastic Man end up
traveling to the Middle East in order to
find the guy who effectively has the
biological weapon and then the rest of
the Justice League travels directly to
razal ghoul's head quarters now for
Superman and Batman once they get into
the room with the Lazarus Pit Batman
basically says Rosal ghoul has my
parents right so that's how so much of
this is impacting me on a personal level
but where Superman goes to respond and
try to free the parents there's red
Kryptonite up there and so he ultimately
ends up basically backing down not only
that like razal ghoul is just kind of
like the heck with it right so he hits
the button the the caskets right the the
the bodies of Batman's parents come
crashing down right getting ready to
smash into the Laz pit Martian Manhunter
shows up and basically saves them right
and that's when Aquaman shows up here he
starts crushing everybody and basically
decimating everybody now when it comes
to the guy that in the Middle East like
Wonder Woman in plastic man you know
they basically save the day and they
tell him like you know no one's going to
remember you if you die you're not going
to be a martyr you're just going to be
like a dude who did a thing here in the
Middle East inside a global war and
you're basically going to kill the world
and so they get him to not do it and
then that's it right and it's the least
important thing nobody cares but in
effect the day saved because razal ghoul
himself actually makes an Escape right
like in all the chaos and all the
pandemonium he basically gets away right
and so it's one of these things where
like they don't really catch the villain
and so the real thing here right the
ending of all this the real thing is
everybody sitting down the whole of the
Justice League once they realize that
there's nothing more that they can do
there the question now turns to what do
we do about Batman right like what do we
do about this guy now one of the first
things they do is they all talk about
the idea of trust and it comes in two
forms the first is by way of humanity
but the second is with each other and
while sure they are earning the trust of
humanity still to a degree because one
of the things to keep in mind this is
technically JLA this was the series that
was launched in 1998 but you're talking
within the DC landscape not that long
after the events of like Crisis on
infinite Earth so for the most part like
the grand reboot and all that kind of
stuff that DC did so superheroes haven't
been around for a super long amount of
time as far as humanity is concerned so
they're still kind of earning the trust
of superheroes right as far as the
sliding time scale of DC Comics goes but
when it comes to the Justice League the
team only functions at its peak capacity
when everyone trusts each other
implicitly that each member has to trust
the person next to them with their life
if it comes down to it Batman has
demonstrated that not only does he not
trust anybody in the Justice League he
actually has contingencies on how to
take each one of them down so in effect
they now see Batman as a clear and
present danger but at the end of the day
he is a member of the league and that's
where the struggle comes into play was
this an immensely egregious act against
the league yes does it wipe away any
instance in the history of the team when
he saved someone's life when he's done
something beneficial for the Justice
League as a whole no and so that's where
the struggle comes in does he stay or
does he go and each member of The League
goes through
and votes now they also asked Batman
what was your motivation for this why do
these Batman protocols exist in the
first place and the answer that he gave
albeit off panel is provided by Superman
when he says that the Justice League are
the most powerful beings on the planet
but even the Justice League is not above
being manipulated the people that they
help do they worry about that should
they worry about that so yes it was all
a precaution it was a just in case but
this shows Batman was doing it without
their knowledge he was doing it in
secret hence the lack of trust between
them and Batman now for Martian
Manhunter this is a particularly
difficult situation because even in the
early days of his character he had
created a kind of dossier on the Justice
League and figured out how to take out
each member of the Justice League now
ultimately it was only information he
never actually constructed plans he
never set up elaborate traps he hasn't
done what Batman did right kind of
created a template and an outline that
if someone like razal gou got their
hands on they could Implement with
ruthless efficiency and take down the
entire team still it's the knowledge
that in some capacity he didn't
necessarily trust them and that's when
like his loyalty is called into question
by Iron Man right like you're taking his
side you would as I remember you used to
keep dossier on us yourself and his
response is that was a very long time
ago this is not about me this is about
Batman and so Martian Manhunter says I
in no way approve of Batman's actions
but I would be a hypocrite to view them
as a cause for expulsion I say he stays
right Kyle rner says that he stays right
votes that he be allowed to stay there
the reason for this and this is one of
the coolest things he says for months
I've been friendly to a guy who's been
looking at me like I was a crash test
dummy but I got this ring through the
same dumb luck that could have delivered
it to some sicko and the thought of that
happening makes me respect why someone
would want to figure out its fail safe
even not tell us that they were doing
that so that we could not devise a way
around it with that kind of thinking
maybe we'd still have a coast city and
so what we're talking about here right
specifically he's talking about how
Jordan right when how Jordan became
Parallax in Emerald Twilight going into
like zero hour crisis in time and trying
to attack all of creation and blinking
the universe out of existence and
bringing it back when it was all that
kind of stuff no one had really sat down
and asked what if Hal Jordan goes nuts
right like what if this guy loses his
mind and becomes a villain You could
argue that it was naivity you could
argue any number of things but
calamities like that are part of the
reason why Batman did what he did and so
at the end of the day that's Kyle
rainer's line of logic if how Jordan
taught us anything it's how easily one
man can fall and with unlimited power
that comes with the Green Lantern ring
how much Havoc they can unleash not just
across earth but across all of creation
and so Wonder Woman's whole response
here is like I vote for expulsion at the
end of the day I cannot forgive this
right I cannot trust a man like that I
have no confidence fighting alongside a
person that would do something like this
right Plastic Man is just like thinking
about it for a second you know and it's
just kind of like I mean sure like I owe
Batman right know Batman's definitely
helped me out but at the end of the day
he can't forgive what happened to him
because his weakness is the left side of
the refrigerator so he's just like get
him out of here and then it all comes
down to Superman he's the Swing Vote
right three for three against he's the
final guy and the questions asked like
you know Batman better than anybody else
here do you think he knows each of us
well enough to know how you will vote
and how we will vote and before any of
them can get an answer when they get out
into the Justice League Watchtower
Batman's taken off he knows exactly what
the vote's going to be that they're
going to vote him out with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end let me know what you
guys think about it down in the comments
section and I will catch you all later
peace